Hello everybody. Welcome to a new episode of the
Center. I'm your host as always Ricardo Lobs.
And today I'm joined for a third time by Doctor
Robert Sapolsky. And today we're talking about his latest
book, Determined The Science of Life without free will
. And I'm also leaving the links to our first
two interviews in the description of this one. So
Doctor Sapolsky, welcome back to the show. It's
always a pleasure to everyone. Well, likewise seeing
you again and uh glad we're on the other side
of the pandemic. A pleasure to be here.
OK. So in our first two interviews, we
talked a lot about the science of human behavior and
this time focusing on questions surrounding free will and determinism
. Are there specific aspects of the science of human
behavior that you would deem to be the most important
here when considering these types of questions? Well,
um just as a preamble, my, my song
and dance is that there's no free will. We
have none whatsoever. Um which puts me fairly far
on the extreme of the continuum of people thinking about
this. Um but that we have no free will
at all. And this is relevant to everything about
how we became, who became uh individually, all
of that, why you just did what you did
. Um But in terms of where that's most important
, um just to focus on the very narrow area
, which is anything but narrow. Um The biggest
implication of that is none of us are entitled to
anything. None of us have earned to be treated
any differently than anyone else. Of course, we
may need to be treated differently. Uh Like if
you're uncontrollably violent, people have to be protected from
you. Um If you have extremely good motor skills
through no, you know, achievement of your own
, uh Maybe you're a candidate to be a good
neurosurgeon, but none of us have earned the right
to have our needs be considered more important than anyone
else's. And so, uh it's one thing to
try to answer the question of free will. I
mean, if it exists or not, but another
thing is why and when people believe in free will
, I mean, are there specific cues that people
pay attention to specific variables that play a role in
how much free will people attribute to themselves or to
someone else when evaluating a particular action? Well,
you're right and people almost universally uh believe that they
are the agents of their action. Um Like 90%
of philosophers fall into a camp uh called compatible list
views of free will. These are people, they're
not saying there's magic, they're not taking theological stances
, whatever they say. Yeah, the world is
made of atoms, we're made of cells like we
believe in all that stuff. Yet, somehow here's
how free will still like pops out of your brain
and do a lot of hand waving at that point
. Um So it's incredibly common view. Um Like
all of our other features of our beliefs and temperaments
, um It's kind of context dependent people really,
really are more likely to believe in free will if
someone's complimenting them and saying good job, they're really
looking like to like, likely to under circumstances where
things have come up short. I mean, there's
, there's this classic dichotomy and sort of us,
them thinking that with them, when thems do something
awful, it's constitutional. That's what they're like.
They've always been like, they'll always be like,
and when one of us does something awful, it's
situational. Yeah, you have to understand they were
under a lot of stress, there were financial pressures
, they had just been whatever, um, as
to how stable our us this is and we're often
being pretty nasty when we're attributing unchangeable them ness to
them. Um, in that regard, we're very
, very malleable when it comes to how characteristically free
we are. When things are going well, people
believe in free will when things are not, there's
a tendency to go in the other direction but not
in a globalized. There's no free will whatsoever.
Here's the extenuating circumstance that screwed me up just now
that kept me from being the wondrous free, consistent
person that I am. Yeah, something came up
. But overall, overall we are the captains of
our fate. Mhm But uh let me ask you
about one criticism that perhaps many people, scientists particularly
would have of uh your position. So we have
a, a good understanding or at least to some
extent of the science of human behavior, the factors
that play a role there uh from genetics to the
environment and culture. But uh I mean, there's
still lots and lots of details that we are missing
. And it's really hard to be able to predict
with a very high level of accuracy how people will
behave in any particular point in time. So,
the fact that there's still fairly low predictability, do
you think that that's an argument against your position?
Um No, and that's, that's like a fantastic
counter ment to bring up because it's very essential.
It, it obviously is very essential. Um Like
I, I have sort of a hobby by now
that I uh help uh public defenders uh who are
lawyers defending poor people who can't afford uh their own
lawyers in murder cases for people who have a history
of traumatic childhoods, uh concussive head trauma and such
teaching juries about the brain. And what always happens
is I get to do a two hour presentation and
then the prosecuting attorney gets to cross examine me and
they always nail me on exactly these lines. So
, are you saying every single person with this type
of brain damage would do what this guy did?
I'd say, no, we can't say that.
Could you have predicted this guy? No, we
can't. Um Part of it, a fundamentally deep
response is um when you look at uh chaotic systems
, systems that run on chaotic system, like us
, our brains, our cells, our molecules,
our societies, um a critical thing about them is
they are unpredictable. They're still deterministic and lots of
people mistake sort of chaotic and the unpredictability of it
as proof that somehow we could transcend our molecules.
But on that level, in this very fundamental way
, um systems that are entirely deterministic can nonetheless be
completely unpredictable. A much more mundane answer is,
well, yeah, we're still finding out stuff.
And when you look at our knowledge about sort of
the biology of human behavior, like 99% of what
we've learned about it has been in the last century
, 75% has been in the last 50 years,
51% has been in the last decade, 25% of
it has been since like we started this broadcast or
whatever, like the rate at which knowledge is pouring
in is incredibly fast. So there, there's this
sort of indirect cheating strategy that one can then say
, which is OK if we're all going to accept
that tonight. At midnight. That's it. Science
is done. We're never gonna find out anything new
again. This is everything we know at this point
. The answer is, yeah. Nonetheless, we
can't predict a whole lot about human behavior. Um
But everything we know about the exponential increase in knowledge
is over and over and over, we're gonna continue
this pattern of saying, oh, I had no
idea. Biology had something to do with that.
And like you have a choice at this point,
do you wanna be on the cutting edge of viewing
that we are nothing more or less than biological machines
or do you wanna be like the history of science
example in a century of just the primitiveness of what
people still believed at the time. And so one
of the things uh also that people bring to the
table in discussions surrounding free will and that people use
in law and in the courtroom has to do with
intent. So, from a scientific perspective, what
is intent exactly? And what do we know about
it? And do you think that its intent in
any way would make for a good case for free
will in any way? Yes. Let me,
let me just be really uh sort of over the
top here. Um As a scientist, my definition
of intent as a subject to consider when thinking about
free will. Um intent can be defined as boring
as hell and totally irrelevant. Um OK. Why
is that? Um the entire legal system, as
you said, runs on that. Um, when
somebody did something awful, did they intend to do
it? And did they know that they had alternative
options? Um And did they understand what the consequences
were going to be? Um And if the answer
to all of that is? Yeah, lock them
up. They intended to do what they did and
they knew there were alternatives. Um And in sort
of the neuroscience world of free will where intent comes
in is the most influential crazy making experiment of all
time in the field. This is something that came
in the early 19 eighties by a man named Benjamin
Lit. And you read any paper about the biology
of free will and like the person is almost required
by law to mention lit by the second paragraph,
these were these amazing studies. He took people and
wired them up with sort of electroencephalograms, eegs to
record brain activity in different areas. This was like
Neanderthal era technology at the time, you couldn't do
brain imaging then. But this very simple approach.
Um he said to people, OK, whenever you
want, press this button and they had things to
tell when the pressing process actually started by seeing when
muscles started constricting in his arm. And they could
see what was happening in the motor cortex, the
part of the brain telling those muscles and they could
see the parts of the brain that would tell another
part to tell another part to tell the motor cortex
to do that. And the earth shattering finding that
he came up with was all of this playing out
in about a half second or so. You could
tell when the brain had decided it was time to
press the button because before the person was conscious of
their intention to do it by about 200 milliseconds,
2/10 of a second. And oh my God,
your brain has decided before you were conscious of intending
to do this. And everyone like went crazy over
this because this is just proven there was no free
will until like people started arguing about. When do
you become aware of intention? And is that different
from when you intend to do something? And,
and you know, all this philosophical stuff of,
is there a difference between intending to do something and
intending to stop yourself from doing something? The difference
between free will and free won't? And they're still
fighting about this. This is 40 years later for
a scientist, there was like a paper a couple
of years ago entitled like Livid. Had no idea
what he was talking about or, or something slightly
more like formal than that for people to still be
telling you that your science was wrong 40 years after
you did it, this is like immortality for a
scientist. They're still fighting about what this finding means
. Does your brain know that you're intending to do
something before you're consciously aware of it. And I
scream every time I see yet another one of these
studies because as I said, it's boring as hell
and totally irrelevant. And in a courtroom as well
, did this person intend to do that? Because
none of it asks the only relevant question there is
. Oh, yeah. Where did that intent come
from? Where did it come from in the first
place? Because to answer the question of, did
the brain have intent before you did that's playing out
in 2/10 of a second when you're asking, where
did that intent come from? What does that have
to do with what was going on in your brain
one second ago? And what was happening in the
environment one minute ago? And what hormone levels were
like one day ago and how traumatic or stimulating the
previous one year had been and what your adolescence was
like in your childhood and your fetal life and your
genes and the culture your ancestors invented because that influenced
how your mother was raising you within a minute of
birth. Where did that intent come from? And
the metaphor I use in the book is deciding whether
or not there's free will based on what's going on
in that last half second and only knowing what the
intent was is like deciding whether you like a movie
or not by just having seen the final three minutes
of it because you've missed everything. It doesn't matter
if the person intended to or not. Where did
that intent come from? And that's where the legal
system falls apart in terms of their thinking about,
you know, punishment and blame. And that's where
most thinking about whether or not there's free will falls
apart because everybody is just interested in their brain imaging
studies telling you what happened in the last three milliseconds
. And that tells you nothing because something about what
happened to you this morning had something to do with
it. Something about your fetal life had something to
do with it. Something about the culture, your
answer came up with 500 years ago, had something
to do with it. And when you look at
all those pieces from one second before to millennia before
and you put all those pieces together, there's not
a damn inch in there to shoehorn in an ocean
of free will operating independent of all of that stuff
. Mhm So when it comes to behavioral science,
we always hear about nature versus nurture genes, the
environment does when it comes to free will specifically,
does it matter at all if uh we're talking about
uh for example, biological factors or environmental factors?
I mean, do we have any more control,
for example, over our environment and how it affects
our behavior than we have over our gyms, for
example, zero in both cases in the fundamental ways
. I mean, what one is obliged to do
in my business at this point is saying, nature
and nurture always interact and you can't pull them apart
and asking which contributes more is like what's contributing more
to the area of this rectangle, the length or
the width they always interact and that sort of thing
um within this realm. Um The summary I would
get at is we are nothing more or less than
the sum of our biology, which we had no
control over and its interactions with the sum of our
environment over which we had no control over. And
they're completely inseparable. I mean, it's the simplest
example of like, oh, how important was environment
in this sort of case and its interaction with biology
? Wow, what explains the fact that I'm sitting
here right now and have a occupation that carries some
prestige and westernized culture and all of that, what
did environment have to do with it? Starting with
environment prenatal environment. The fact that my, my
mother was not suffering from malaria or Chagas disease or
like any such thing and wasn't protein starved because she
was a nomadic pastoralist in the Sahel, in Africa
. And like, oh, like we're talking like
at that level already. That's like what we're talking
already at that level. That's part of the brain
that you wound up being uh handed to you here
in adulthood. Um All of that stuff matters and
it's inseparable. Mhm One very interesting thing that you
talk about in the book is the Behavioral Science slash
Biology of luck. What is that about it?
It's, that's ultimately everything, everything we're talking about
here. Um Another way of saying, oh,
the sum of our biology and this interaction with the
sum of our environment is we are nothing more or
less than the outcome of our luck and anyone who
claims otherwise that they earned their good luck or that
it makes sense to punish them for their bad luck
. Um All we are is the outcome of biology
, interacting with environment in the context of luck.
And there's this whole thing like child development, um
try to make sense of who turns out to be
like the the violent adults and the drug addicts and
all the, all the bad outcomes and like no
surprise childhood has a huge amount to do with it
and it's been formalized into this thing. Um At
least in sort of uh United States called your ace
score A ce the sum of your adverse childhood experiences
. And there's this ace like questionnaire scoring system where
you can get from 0 to 10 and zero is
you had no adversity 10 is like you had all
of the following 10 horrible things happen to you.
Were you a witness to physical violence or psychological violence
at home? Were you a victim of physical violence
or psychological violence? Were you a victim of sexual
abuse? Were you in a broken family? Was
there a weapon at home when you was there,
a family member who was incarcerated this whole list there
going from 0 to 10. Um, and what
you see is for every single step, every point
you add to somebody's ace score. Um, there's
about a 35% increased likelihood that they're going to be
involved in violent antisocial behavior by the time they're adult
. If they're a male, there's about a 35%
increased chance that they're gonna have a teenage pregnancy.
If they're female, about a 35% increased chance of
either that they're gonna have substance abuse and addiction problems
every step in the way. And this is one
way of formalizing like this is the quantified science of
shitty luck in childhood. And it has always struck
me that at the same time. Instead of making
it an adverse childhood experience score, you could make
a ridiculously lucky childhood experience score. Did your parent
or parents read books to you? Did you have
a stable income? Um Did you never have to
worry about food? Did you play games and laugh
at home? Whatever? Come up with a score
of that and it's gonna tell you forever. Each
step in those, there's a 35% increase that you're
gonna be working a prestigious white collar job someday and
have an office and a secretary or who knows just
a different way of explaining the same thing. Um
Everything that we frame as morality is instead the outcome
or of good or bad luck. And we have
built a world in which we punish or reward people
over the luck they had nothing to do with.
Mhm. But, uh, as we go through
, uh childhood adolescence, adulthood and our prefrontal cortices
develop, we tend to gain or acquire more self-control
, more impulse control. Does that not count at
least as a few more degrees of rhythm? Right
. Let's look at the sentence you just said as
we get older, don't we acquire more frontal cortical
self control? What does acquire mean? It means
you're lucky enough to be in an environment that would
have taught you that it means you're lucky enough to
have a brain at that point where you could learn
from those experiences. It means that you're lucky enough
that the counter examples every day when you finish school
and went outside and there was the, your gang
telling you let's go rob that liquor store. Um
Let's do something impulsive that reinforces your frontal cortex not
working very well. How many of those were going
on at the end of the day? Do you
go home and you're bullied by somebody at home and
anything you heard during the day about like the wonderful
path ahead of you? Thanks to self control goes
out the window. Be Yeah, we learned.
Oh, wow. Didn't you learn somewhere along the
way that self control is a bad thing for you
if you're a fetus and your mother is very stressed
and secreting a lot of stress hormones. You're going
to be born with a frontal cortex that's already less
developed than average and newborns. Meaning 15 years later
, you're getting great lessons in life about the importance
of self control. And by the time you were
a damn fetus, you were already less likely than
average to be able to learn those lessons and benefit
from them every step along the way. Where did
that intent come from? Where did that learning come
from? Where did the opportunity for that learning come
from? And it's always, you know, all
that stuff that brought you to this moment over which
you had no control. And when it comes to
our psychological traits, we know, for example,
from disciplines like behavior genetics that there's the role of
genes and then the shared environment, the non shared
environment, unique experiences we go through. Isn't there
any space at all there for some, uh I
mean, for us to have some sort of be
, be able to play some active role in the
kind of person that we're going to become? Absolutely
. Um And that's one of the ways in which
uh people should avoid the hysteria of deciding genes,
determine everything that genes are the most interesting things.
If nothing else, you have this whole field of
epigenetics, the ways in which experience can change how
readily genes of yours are turned on or off.
For the rest of your life in some cases.
OK. So we're moved away from a genetic deterministic
picture for a zillion reasons, uh both biological and
environmental. Um But you're saying, can't we choose
to take an action to take a conscious action which
will change our destiny? And the answer is not
in the slightest, you look at two people who
were given an opportunity and one is this person who
every single split in the road, they always take
the wrong direction. They never miss an opportunity to
miss an opportunity at everyone. You could have.
They, they would have given you that job.
They were offering you a scholarship. The guy said
you didn't have to drive the car when they were
going to do the robbery and oh my God,
every time that person makes the wrong choice, every
time they come up with the wrong intent and where
did that come from? And when we seemingly have
made a major decision on our part about something in
life, are you going to rob the store?
Are you going to study hard? Are you gonna
propose marriage to this person or you? Who knows
what? Um And that feels intent. Um Everything
about the biology and this interaction with the environment that
came before that is what brought you to that moment
. Like from everything. Like if you're hungry,
you're more likely to commit an antisocial violent act.
If somebody smells good to you, their pheromones,
you're more likely to find them. You claim that
they are more vis visually physically attractive if you,
you know all this stuff, what, what this
, at the split in the road? Do you
make the right decision or not? What this taps
into is? I think the most pernicious way in
which people hold on to. Yes. Yes.
Yes. Yes. There's biology and we have brains
and all of that and it just made a brain
gunk. Um, but we have free will,
we have free will. Is this dichotomy people bring
in? You look at somebody who's 7 ft four
and of course, they're a great basketball player or
you look at somebody and they have particular ratio of
slow twitch to fast twitch fibers in their leg muscles
and of course they turn out to be a good
marathoner or maybe even you understand enough about receptors for
this or that neurotransmitter. And of course they have
a good memory or good. Any of these.
We're pretty good at accepting the biology of what our
natural attributes are. Some people have lovely voices and
others don't. And they're never gonna sing in an
opera. Some people have, yes, there's these
natural attributes. OK. Ok. Ok. Science
biology has something to do with that. But oh
, where free will comes in is what you do
with your attributes? Do you squander them? Do
you work hard to overcome your limitations? Do you
, are you one of these people like you go
on youtube and there's unbelievable examples of this, of
like marathoners and like important races where they collapse 53
ft from the finish line and they crawl, they
crawl to the very end. And you say,
oh my God, this is amazing with what they
did with what they were given. Or you find
like somebody raised in poverty in a horrible neighborhood and
all of that who somehow winds up like with their
Nobel Prize at the other end, or somebody who
grows up in great wealth and privilege and they're a
junkie by the time they're 20 they've spent half their
fortune. Oh, your attributes you have no control
over. That's the biology. What do you do
with the attributes? That's where we have a world
of, oh, what a self indulgent squander.
What an inspiring role model, how they worked to
overcome. There's something in there that we believe that
things like your memory or whether you have perfect pitch
or things like that are made of biology and how
hard you work and your self control and how indulgent
you are and all of that somehow that's made of
other stuff that's not made of biology. And when
you look at it like what happened to you as
a fetus is going to have something to do with
the construction of your part of the brain that has
something to do with whether it splits in the road
, you always make the bad decision, you every
step of this is biology as well. Um But
there's this very strong emotional pull to differentiate between the
two and willpower and backbone and fortitude and all of
that, that's the stuff we admire because that's the
true measure of who somebody is independent of their neurons
and molecules of it's made of the same stuff.
And so um is there any space for an idea
like meritocracy in this sort of deterministic world? I
mean, if someone just so happens to have the
psychological traits that tend to correlate with success, for
example, in industrialized societies, like greed, conscientiousness
, high intelligence and so on. Should we at
from, from a scientific perspective? Of course,
I'm not talking about uh philosophy, a philosophical perspective
nor any of that. Does it make sense to
attribute any personal merit to them? Yeah. Um
The only possible, scientifically acceptable and morally acceptable conclusion
from all of this is there's no circumstance in which
blame and punishment make moral sense or are uh are
good things in and of themselves. And likewise,
there's no circumstance in which praise and reward are virtues
in and of themselves because nobody earned one or the
other, that sort of thing. This comes with
two provisos though um the first one is like every
now and then it's useful to punish someone because it
changes their behavior in an effective way or it's useful
to praise somebody because in an instrumental sense. Um
Praise and blame could be useful, not because of
what somebody did in the past that this is retribute
but for shaping their future behavior just in like a
psychological engineering kind of way. Um So that's not
saying it's not possible, it's never useful, but
just as another way of influence the influencing the biological
machine. Um The more fundamental level is when you
say crazy stuff like I just did to people they
say, oh, so you want just murderers running
around the streets or? Oh, you just want
it randomly picked who's going to do brain surgery to
take out your tumor. No, of course not
. Even if you get rid of the entire criminal
justice system as it now appears. And as we
should, because it's built on biological nonsense of the
most destructive kind. Nonetheless, people who are uncontrollably
dangerous and violent where you can't fix them, you
gotta protect people from them. Um, a car
whose brakes don't work. You don't let it out
on the street, you put it in the garage
and you like, don't drive it, but you
don't preach to either that violent person or to the
car whose brakes don't work that they have a crummy
rotten soul and they don't deserve to be able to
do this and what you have to do instead is
use a term that's more and more in like this
. People thinking this way is they have to be
quarantined, quarantine them so that they're not dangerous to
anyone and not an inch more. And not because
there's anything about it that they deserve the brakes don't
work on their car and then the flip side is
exactly the same. Oh, my God. So
, what, we should just have a random lottery
as to who, who, like, does brain
surgery on you. No, of course not.
Just as you can't have dangerous people on the street
, You need the most competent people out there doing
the medicine, doing the legal stuff, writing whatever
it is that takes um skill that matters, that's
really important. But you just the same, you
can't sit there and tell that person because they have
a wonderful soul or a wonderful self discipline or whatever
that they deserve to have this ridiculously large income.
Like a world built around blaming people for their antisocial
behavior makes no sense. And a world built around
rewarding people for their prosocial behavior or their expertise makes
no sense either. Um And is ultimately just as
morally corrupt because if you say you are a brain
surgeon and getting enormous societal prestige because you did something
where you earned it, you deserve to do that
and be in that position makes as little sense biologically
as saying the brain, the uh the murderer with
a history of frontal cortical damage deserves to be in
prison all of that. Um Yeah, it's the
flip side. A meritocracy makes no sense. A
justice system built around retribution makes no sense either.
But at the same time, dangerous people should not
be allowed to damage people. And competent people should
be more likely to be running the world than less
competent people. But no one should feel shame or
pride for which end of those Katina they wind up
on. But even if there's not really space for
blame or praise or to consider or to think that
someone is responsible for their own actions, do you
think that it would still make sense to talk about
punishment? At least as a deterrence measure or for
example, blaming or praising someone just because we know
scientifically that if we do that, we would be
disincentivizing bad behavior, incentivizing good behavior and conditioning people
to behave in better ways. Absolutely. And it's
the same biology that like you take a, a
sea snail and it could learn that when you like
bop it on the head with a pencil, it
retracts its gill mechanism or some. Yeah, you
can shape sea snails behavior, you could shape human
behavior, you could shape human behavior to be more
or less adaptive, blah, blah, all of
that. And yeah. Yeah, sometimes it requires
punishment and sometimes it requires praise and reward. Um
But just because that's like another thing you can do
, sometimes intervene with somebody who's got problems and make
sure they uh they get enough calories in their diet
and things will go better sometimes like you hit someone
over the head and say they, they can't do
this anymore and they'll stop doing some rotten behavior.
Yes. But never with a sense that you are
doing a moral good because that's completely irrelevant. It's
just another realm in which we as biological machines can
be shaped in our behavior. And what do you
think about, uh, the idea that some people
put forth that, uh, ok, even if
we know that free will does not exist that it
doesn't make sense to talk about free will. People
should still believe in free will because if they don't
, they will be worse people. I mean,
do you, or do you think on the other
hand that, uh, telling people that, uh
, they should abandon their belief in free will would
actually improve their lives? Ok. This is,
this is ultimately like the most important question to ask
whether or not we have free will. Should we
all believe that we do? Um, one worry
which you bring up is if we stop believing in
free will, we're all gonna become murderers and cheats
and liars and we will run amok. Um And
this is the thing people worry about, uh,
most instantly and there's a cruel experimental psychology literature showing
that if you take like volunteer test subjects and you
manipulate them into feeling like there is less free will
than they thought there was 10 minutes later, they're
more likely to cheat on a test, they're more
likely to do something crummy to somebody else. When
they're playing a game, morality and ethical behavior goes
down. That's it. That's exactly what, like
the problem is when you tell people, um,
like you can't be held responsible for anything. They've
run amok. Just like if you convince someone that
there is no God and thus there's no punishment,
they run amok also. And then you look closer
at it and because there's this parallel literature, you
have test subjects and you convince them, manipulate them
into believing, lesson God and right afterward, they
cheat more and they do the same crummy stuff.
But now you do a different version of these studies
, get someone who comes in and says, I
haven't believed in free will for 10 years or I
haven't believed in God since I was a teenager or
any. You get people who have thought that way
and felt that way for a long time who got
there. Not because some like psychology professor is manipulating
them in this environment. But you get people like
that who've thought through this for a long time.
And they are exactly as moral as the most religious
people and the people with the strongest sense of belief
in free will. And this fascinates me, like
in terms of the God issue, you look at
people who very, very strongly believe in God and
the whole show that goes along with that or very
, very strongly believes there is no God. And
as I said, there's no difference in their levels
of ethical behavior and it's very high in both cases
who are the ones who are less ethical, the
ones who are in between, the ones who say
, oh, I don't know, I guess there's
God and like, I make sure the kids learn
something about it because it's good for them and like
, the, the ho are good or say God
, I don't, I don't actually care. Maybe
there's not a God, but it's like, what
does it have to do with me? The people
who are like indifferently religious or apathetically atheistic, the
ones in the middle, those are the ones who
you readily manipulate their moral behavior, one direction or
the other. If you've spent a hell of a
long time sitting and thinking about the root of human
goodness and evil and what we owe our fellow humans
and is their purpose in life that transcends us.
It doesn't really matter if your conclusion is there is
a God or there is no God or we're free
agents or we have no free will whatsoever. You're
one of the ones who thought long and hard about
it and both sets of conclusions you come out as
being more ethically moral than your average person. Um
So people are not going to run amok if they
are raised from the very beginning to think this is
not a world where it is fair. To blame
anyone and I don't deserve to get this or that
reward more than anyone else. They're going to be
past the notion. Oh, no one's gonna hold
me responsible. I can go and stab the old
lady there with any luck to be past that by
the time they're like, 20 years old. And
I was here hearing all the time people saying that
hard determinist were all nihilists and atheists and they were
all the time, uh, pillaging and raping and
murdering people. Exactly. Because that's, that's the
logical first thing. Um, the logical second thing
that was also, went back in your question is
when you get past, oh, should I run
amok and do whatever I want all of that is
, should I get depressed as hell? Because there's
no purpose to any of this? There's this huge
existential void out there. Should I like, is
this terrible thing to have people believe in terms of
their mental health and stuff? Um, and a
point, like, it took me five years to
write this book and the 1st 4.5 years I was
thinking the answer to that was gonna have to be
. Yeah. And that sucks. And it's awful
. But, you know, that's how things work
and, like, come on, we need to
be adults and face reality and it finally struck me
the much more meaningful answer to it, which is
, if you are convinced there's no free will and
you get totally depressed and empty void because it means
your accomplishments. You didn't really earn that. The
people who loved you don't really love you for who
you are. But for biological stuff that you helped
this old woman cross the street just now. Not
because you're a good person, but because that's how
you function as machine. All that. Oh my
God. This is so depressing. If that's your
response, you're one of the lucky ones. You've
got the luck and privilege to sit there and say
, oh my God, maybe I really didn't earn
my wonderful university degree. Oh my God. Maybe
I didn't really deserve to be liked by people because
of my personality. If you're someone who has spent
your whole life paying the price of your parents,
poverty or the fact that you don't have an attractive
face or the fact that you have the genes that
deep predispose you towards obesity and people recoil from overweight
people. Or because you turned out not to be
so smart or it turns out you can't control your
behavior because of biology. All that getting rid of
the free will concept does is be liberating. You
don't have a shitty soul because your life has not
turned out that well. And for most people,
that's the much more important outcome to all of this
than deciding, oh, I guess I really didn't
earn my million dollars to be a millionaire. Um
, for most people getting rid of the concept of
free will is not gonna make us like crazy and
nihilistic. Um It's gonna be liberating. Mhm But
uh going back just for a second to one of
the initial points I brought to the table when it
comes to the fact that we do not yet have
a complete science of human behavior and we cannot 100%
predict how someone will behave in a particular situation.
Uh What if someone heard your arguments of behavioral scientist
and said, oh OK, Dr Sapolsky, your
arguments are great, the science is awesome. But
since we still do not have a complete picture of
human behavior, at least for the time being,
I will refrain from making absolute claims, uh claims
regarding free will. I will wait and see.
I mean, basically what I'm asking you is do
you think that the fact that we do not yet
have a complete science of free will uh would make
uh such a claim that we should reframe, refrain
from making such absolute claims about free will uh make
sense, right? Um Two types of answers there
. The first one is um yeah, it's gonna
be so hard to subtract out thinking there's free will
because we don't have the solid scientific facts yet.
For centuries, all we've done over and over is
figure out that responsibility turns out not to have something
to do with our behavior. Turns out hailstorms are
not caused by witches, it turns out people who
have epileptic seizures are not possessed by Satan or even
within the last 50 years or so. It turns
out people come down with the disease. Schizophrenia,
not because their mothers were psycho dynamically, monsters who
hated them. And all that happened at each one
of those points is you tell the mothers of,
you know, hundreds of thousands of people with schizophrenia
, it's not your fault. It's a neuro genetic
disorder. All you've done is freed them all you've
done when you figured out that this kid in your
classroom where you're a teacher just can't learn to read
and this kid is just lazy and un mot no
, there's something in their cortex that could be identified
by scientists so that they reverse letters in their mind
. They have dyslexia, it's not their fault.
We can't explain yet who gets dyslexia and who doesn't
? We have only hints from prenatal environment, blah
, blah, blah. But we know enough that
it is both intellectually and morally bankrupt to decide that
this child is lazy and unmotivated and to instead recognize
we've identified their particular type of biological constraint and all
that's going to happen in the future is more and
more and more of those. And all we can
be at this point is accepting that a whole lot
of things that pulls out the ugliest in us in
the way of judgment. We're gonna wind up saying
, oh my God, I had no, I
had no idea. It had something to do with
that or framed a different way. Yeah. Yeah
. Yeah, we can't sit there and say somebody
with this sort of upbringing, we can absolutely predict
that they're gonna wind up going to a top university
or wind up being a multiple murderer. Yeah,
we can't predict that yet. The science isn't good
enough. The science is good enough on a population
level. Any time you could look at an entire
population and say for every increased incidence of a horrible
childhood experience, you've just increased 35% the likelihood that
they're going to be arrested by the time they're 20
you got enough science. At that point, you've
got enough science that you better know you have no
leg to stand on. If you sit there and
say this kid this 20 year old, what can
I say? They're just plain evil. This kid
, if you 35% for each step, there's enough
science at this point, there's enough knowledge there.
If you have, I don't know whatever percent predictability
that if your mother was drinking heavily when you're a
fetus, you've got this likelihood of having an IQ
below this. And someday when you're failing classes,
we know enough science already. In all these cases
, we know enough science because we run an entire
society on statistical guilt and statistical wonderful accomplishments. And
we know enough now to know that those are not
OK. So I have one last question then what
would it take for, for someone to convince you
that you're wrong and actually free will exists? OK
? Here's, here's my pain in the ass response
. And the philosophers are going to like, oh
come on, give me a break. Um The
version that they start off with is oh, come
on, give me a break is you've just done
something, you've pulled a trigger on a gun,
you just did something consequential And here's the muscles that
contract it. And here's the three motor neurons that
just sent that command. And if you wanna convince
us that free will actually exist, show us that
those neurons just did what they did independent of what
any other neuron in the brain was doing at that
moment. If you could do that, you've just
proven free will. And they say, oh come
on, give us a break. That's ridiculous.
A demand. I would demand a whole lot more
than that. I would say. Show me that
those three neurons just told you to pull that trigger
, having nothing to do with what any other neuron
was whispering to it at the time and having nothing
to do with your hormone levels that morning and having
nothing to do with your history of trauma and having
nothing to do with your genes. So show me
that if you had changed any of those, those
neurons would still have done the exact same thing at
that moment, then I'll believe in free will and
you can't, you can't show that because nothing going
on in you right now is anything but the outcome
of all of that stuff that came beforehand, perhaps
unpredictably, perhaps in some nonlinear, non additive cool
way, perhaps in an emergent way that we can't
even begin to mix. But that's all we are
. Nothing more or less and show me a neuron
that just decided to do what it did independent of
everything that came before that millisecond. And if you
could do that, I believe in free will and
uh philosophers are gonna hate it. But what I
think any biologist who knows this stuff would say is
, yeah, that's kind of what you need to
show. That's kind of the proof that is needed
to show that there really is free will and that's
pretty damn unlikely to be able to show that.
OK. So let's see if someone accepts the challenge
. So, yeah, so the book is again
, determined a science of life without free will.
I'm leaving a link within the description box of this
interview. Um Doctor Sapolsky, just before we go
apart from the book, would you like to mention
briefly where people can find you and your work on
the internet? Um Let's see, I'm I am
a medieval peasant in that. Not only don't,
I do Facebook, I don't know how to,
don't, not only do I not do Instagram or
any of these things that my kids say that I
don't understand. So I have no presence there,
but there's a bunch of my lectures that have been
put up on youtube. Um I teach a class
at Stanford every other year on the biology of human
social behavior. That's basically the last hour stretched out
over entire semester. And years ago, Stanford posted
all of those lectures up there and one of these
years I have to update them. So go to
youtube. Uh You'll see I'm doing the exact same
ranting and raving word for word and a number of
those like talks that overlap, but that would be
a good place. Ok, great. So,
Doctor Sapolsky, thank you again for coming on the
show. It's always a great pleasure to talk to
you. Well, likewise, thank you for having
me on and uh till next time this is fun
. Hi guys. Thank you for watching this interview
. Until the end. If you like what I'm
doing, please do not forget to share like,
subscribe, comment and to keep the channel sustainable.
Please consider supporting it on Patreon or paypal. You
can find the links in the description box of the
interview. The show is brought to you by N
Lights learning and development. Then differently check their website
at N lights dot com. I would also like
to give a huge thank you to my main patrons
and paypal supporters, Burger Larson, Jerry Mull Lawrence
, Frederick Sune, Bernard. So all of Alex
Adam Kessel Matthew Winten, Beg Arno Wolf, Tim
Hollows, Erica J. Connors Philip for Connolly.
Then the Mere Robert Winger ruin you. Mark Nevs
Colin Holbrook, Simon Columbus, Phil Kavanagh, Mikel
Stormer, Samuel Andre Francis for the Agns Fergal K
and Hale Herzog and Hes Mark Smith, El S
Wilson JP Charlotte, Adam Hunt. Pas Nele Bach
Guy Madison, Gary G Almansa Zal Adrian. Ye
bin Jean Barbo Julian Price Edward Hall Eden Bruner Douglas
Fry Franco BTO Lotti Gabriel Cortez Orlik Scott Zachary Fish
, Tim Duffy, Sonny Smith, John Ws Daniel
Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Giorgino, Luke Loi
Giorgio, Theophanous Griz Williams and Peter Walla and David
Williams Theo Costa Anton Erickson Charles. More like Shower
Marie Martinez, Coralie Chevalier, Bangalore Larry, the
Lee Junior Old Herringbone Starry Michael Bailey, then Sperber
, Robert Grassy Zor and Jeff mcmahon, Jake Zul
Barnabas Radix, Mark Campbell Thomas Dubner, Luke Neeson
, Christo Kimberly Johnson. Benjamin Gilbert Jessica Nowicki Linda
Brandon, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael Bensley George Katis,
Valentin Steinman, Per Rawley, Kate Von Goler,
Alexander Hubbard, Liam Dua Away Bi ma ma Ali
Mohammadi Perpendicular. And I Herner a special thanks to
my producers is our AJ Frank Luca Stein, Tom
Ween, Bernard Ni Fortis Dixon, Benedict Muller Thomas
Trumble, Catherine and Patrick Tobin. Jean Carlo,
Mon Negro, Al Nick Ortiz and Nick Golden.
And to my executive producers, Mafi Lavender as you
could and Bogdan K I thank you for all.